solo como un recordatorio de dónde
estamos tenemos esta transformación
bastante no lineal y mostramos que si se
acercan un poquito a un punto específico
mientras la transformación está
sucediendo se parece mucho a algo lineal
y así obtuvimos que la matriz que nos
dice el comportamiento lineal es esta de
aquí la cual tiene a todas estas
derivadas parciales involucradas y le
pusimos el nombre de matriz hakobyan y
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
básicamente terminar con lo que estaba
diciendo en el vídeo anterior
voy a calcular todas estas derivadas
parciales y después las voy a evaluar en
el punto menos dos coma menos 1 así que
vamos a hacerlo si me fijo primero en
que es lo que pasa en esta matriz y me
fijo en que es lo que pasa en la primera
componente observa que lo que tenemos es
la derivada de la función f 1 me voy a
tomar la derivada de esta función de
esta que tengo aquí con respecto a x y
si observas esto sería una constante con
respecto a x así que simplemente me
queda la derivada de x con respecto a x
lo cual es muy sencillo
uno y luego debajo de esto vamos a sacar
la derivada de la segunda componente de
f2 de xm que en este caso la yema se ve
como una constante entonces eliminan me
queda la derivada del seno de x lo cual
es el coseno de x déjame ponerlo el
coseno de
y luego finalmente lo que tengo que
hacer es tomarme la derivada de la
primera función con respecto a james
para obtener esta componente de aquí la
primera componente de la segunda columna
entonces aquí tengo f1 de que james y me
voy a tomar la derivada de esta función
que tengo aquí si observas la derivada
con respecto a jett de x bueno es 0 es
una constante y después tengo la
derivada con respecto del seno de james
lo cual me va a dar el coste know de
james lo voy a poner aquí el coche no
deje esto porque bueno eran unas
funciones muy simétricas y acá abajo
en esta última componente me va a quedar
la derivada de la segunda función de f 2
con respecto al yen así que de esta
función voy a obtener la derivada con
respecto a james y finalmente puedes ver
que es simplemente uno porque las
derivadas de ye con respecto y es 1 y la
derivada del seno de x es decir de algo
que no depende de james se va es como
una constante y
entonces aquí me quedaría simplemente
uno así que esta es la matriz hakobyan a
general vista como una función de xy de
jeff pero si queremos entender qué
sucede alrededor del punto menos 2,1
alrededor de este punto específico habrá
que sustituir estos valores aquí adentro
de esta matriz entonces cuando
introducimos el menos 2,1 adentro de
esta matriz voy a obtener lo siguiente
voy a obtener una matriz que en la
primera componente tiene 1 en la primera
componente de la primera columna y en la
segunda componente de la primera columna
tengo el coseno de x pero en este caso x
valer menos 2 así que me quedaría el
coseno de menos 2 que por cierto ya lo
había calculado antes el coseno de menos
2 es aproximadamente aproximadamente
menos 0.42 fue algo que hice antes de
que empezara el vídeo esto si lo quieren
pensar en términos de un número y luego
aquí en la parte superior de las
la columna tengo el coche no deje pero
en este caso llévale uno entonces tengo
el coche no de uno que también ya me
tomé la libertad de calcularlo es
aproximadamente 0.54 0.54 ok y en la
segunda componente de la segunda columna
me quedan simplemente 1 así que esta es
la matriz hakobyan am evaluada en el
punto menos 21 y sólo como una revisión
intuitiva podemos echar un vistazo a la
transformación lineal así es como se
supone que se vería y noten en lo que se
convirtió el primer vector base parece
que tiene las coordenadas 1 - 0.42
cierto tiene su componente s la derecha
que se aproximadamente tan larga como el
mismo vector del comienzo y luego esta
componente hacia abajo la cual creo que
es bastante creíble que sean menos 0.42
y luego del mismo modo esta segunda
columna de la matriz está diciéndonos
qué pasó con el segundo vector base el
cual se ve así y de nuevo su componente
tan larga como comenzó cierto tiene una
longitud de 1 y luego su componente
hacia la derecha es aproximadamente la
mitad de eso y en realidad vemos eso en
el diagrama pero al final es por eso que
se calculan de nuevo esto es bastante
sencillo solo sacan las derivadas
parciales las organizan dentro de esta
cuadrícula y con eso obtienen la matriz
hakobyan así que los veo en el siguiente
vídeo